Hello and welcome to your Unreal training.
In this section, the ICVFX calibration,
we'll be covering lens data and mapping.
My name is Kevin Miller and I am your instructor for
this two-part series and in this course,
we will cover calibration, camera configuration,
camera hardware, media profile implementation.
We will do an overview of the tracking solutions,
talking about the plugins and
the system options that you have available to you.
We will also talk about camera control systems
and create a virtual live link subject.
We'll talk a little bit about the time data monitor
and adjusting sync and timecode,
then we'll walk through lens file creation
and go through our lens distortion mapping.
In the second course that follows this,
we will cover our nodal point calibration as well.